intermittent fasting and low carb can
somebody get me a sandwich hey everyone
i'm abby sharp welcome to abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video we'll be taking a look at
nutritionist and youtuber autumn bates
but first let me tell you what my
sponsor build bar
snack lovers you're gonna love this news
because if you have yet to find a
protein bar that doesn't taste like
chalk listen to me here folks
so good it tastes like a chocolate bar
and a nugget bar had a baby and i'm here
for it oh i'm excited for snack time
today's flavor
um
i don't know guys
i don't know
i got one left because they're a
favorite
peanut butter brownie two of my favorite
things in one how could it be bad really
um
[Music]
mmm she is dense
19 grams of protein what all right i
love these as like a really light snack
all on their own but i also love to pair
them with some fruit or oatmeal or
yogurt like a smoothie for a more
balanced substantial snack but if you
want to try a build bar yourself check
out the link in the description and you
can use my promo code abbysharp15 to get
15 off of your order and folks you can
pause the screen or look at the
description to check out my disclaimer
including a trigger warning to those
with current or previous experiences
with disordered eating as always feel
free to skip this video if it's not
supportive to your journey and of course
if you guys are new here do not forget
to subscribe to this channel ring that
little bell so you never miss out and
follow me on tik tok and instagram at
abby's kitchen okey dokey for those who
don't know autumn is a wellness youtuber
who's focused much of her career on
touting the benefits of intermittent
fasting she offers lots of free content
on her youtube channel and social media
as well as having a number of paid for
programs like her seven day detox and
her 21 day intermittent fasting program
which she references a lot in said free
youtube content so i actually took one
for the team here and paid the 49 for
her 21 day program to like get a little
extra look at some of her supporting
documents but i will be focusing on her
latest what i in a day at the time of
filming because there's a lot to unpack
in that alone let's take a look so
during my fast i always have water right
when i wake up and i also add sea salt
as well this helps to make sure that my
energy levels stay high because a lot of
salt and water gets lost when you are
fasting and first thing in the morning
i'll have like an eighth teaspoon and a
quarter teaspoon depending on how tough
my workout was okay so while the
research in this area is really not
great it is possible that electrolyte
balance can get thrown off by food
deprivation or fasting because you're
not taking in any food with electrolytes
for one and the drop in insulin can also
increase water loss so if you're feeling
some of the symptoms of hyponatremia
like headaches lightheadedness fatigue
nausea and muscle cramps it's definitely
worth seeing if adding a little sodium
can help now in autumn's ebook she says
that experts suggest you may need up to
five grams a day when you're fasting but
i have actually not found any evidence
of that and i looked um and funny enough
she didn't link to a citation for that
one either so i would say unless you're
michael phelps in your workout i'm not
convinced that you need to replenish
that much and interestingly enough there
have actually been studies of low salt
diets and how those are actually related
to increased insulin resistance okay so
the citation she did share in this video
which touted a pretty scary title about
a low salt diet causing insulin
resistance in healthy individuals was
honestly
not a great study at all i expected it
to be you know pretty bad but this is
really bad i'm not gonna get too into it
but the actual difference between the
low salt and the high cell groups was
pretty dismal and the only likely reason
their result yielded any significance
was because they had a large enough
sample sodium research is complicated as
and there's now a lot of debate around
the methods used to suggest that lower
levels of sodium intake may be just as
dangerous as higher amounts like this
would need a whole other video if you'd
like what i'm trying to say here is that
sometimes a single study headline
doesn't tell you a whole lot you really
need to read the findings and the body
of research to be able to form an
unbiased educated stance just putting it
out there now in a totally fasted state
i go for a walk i make sure you get in
about 20 to 30 minutes this helps to
ramp up the fat burning mechanisms
because it is a lower intensity exercise
and it helps to warm up my muscles for
my strength training workouts when your
muscles are actually challenged with
some type of weight training or
resistance training it helps to improve
insulin sensitivity making it easier to
burn fat as fuel so that's not untrue
all exercise will improve insulin
sensitivity and fasted cardio and
resistance training does seem to allow
you to utilize more fat as fuel but this
doesn't necessarily result in a budge on
the scale basically i would say this is
a short-sighted approach if working out
fasted results in a shorter or lower
intensity workout you're gonna burn
fewer net calories overall we also have
evidence that it can eat into protein
stores especially if you're going to
continue to fast for the hours before
and after you train which it seems that
autumn does not to mention having some
fuel on board or immediately after
training isn't absolutely necessary but
it will help you take advantage of the
anabolic sensitivity around this time so
ideally if you're working out fasted in
the morning you'll want to have a meal
with carbs and protein as soon as you
realistically can afterwards from here
center around 8 a.m when i'm going to
have my coffee once i have my coffee i'm
transitioning more into what's called
fasting mimicking grass-fed butter which
is huge super important to make sure
you're using grass-fed butter grass-fed
butter is rich in a short-chain fatty
acid called butyric acid which is really
great for decreasing inflammation in the
gi tract i've had a huge history of gut
inflammation and gut bloating in the
past and this has really helped
obviously paired with the gut healing
aspect of intermittent fasting so i'll
blend in about a tablespoon's worth of
grass-fed butter into my coffee as well
of some
as well as some coconut oil okay so
we've discussed this a bit with our
friend jillian michaels but what autumn
is suggesting is that keto coffee will
technically kick you out of your fast
but it won't kick you out of ketosis
because you aren't consuming enough
carbs or protein to stimulate an insulin
response so you're still getting some of
the alleged benefits of fasting like
suppressed insulin levels with a little
bit of calories and fuel but you're
halting the gut healing benefits she
mentioned aka the migratory motor
complex or mmc so i mentioned the mmc
when i discussed my sibo saga but most
experts suggest you want to aim for at
least one four to five hour break
between meals in the day and the rest
can be closer to maybe two to three
hours with a 12 hour fast or so
overnight you don't necessarily have to
stretch it to like 16 hours especially
if you're only having three solid meals
with breaks in between in the day also i
just gotta say like if she likes butter
and coconut oil in her coffee great you
guys know i don't harp on coffee
preferences but if the obsession over
the butter is for adding butyric acid
for gut health it's probably not your
best bet yes we know that butter is our
best dietary source of butyrate which is
a short chain fatty acid in the gut with
a number of documented health benefits
for gut health and metabolism but butter
is only three to four percent butyrate
and while we don't have strong data
comparing conventional to grass-fed
butter it's assumed that grass-fed may
only be slightly higher than this even
if grass-fed did have more butyrate we'd
still be like splitting hairs here
because the vast majority of the butyric
acid in our diet comes from gut bacteria
fermenting fiber so if you want more
butyrate in your gut focus on fiber and
resistant starch not the minute amounts
that you'd find in a spoonful of fat
ditto for using coconut oil for medium
chain triglycerides which are uniquely
metabolized fats known for their mild
fat burning properties but most of the
research on the benefits of mcts have
been done on pure 100
mct oil not coconut oil which is kind of
a cocktail of fats made of only 50
mct now i have a review of all things
saturated fats including coconut oil
which you can check out in my video
right here so i'll use about a half
serving of each of these like a half
serving of greek yogurt so about a half
cup and then a half serving of protein
powder that way you can get
can't speak that way you can get that
vanilla e flavor from the protein powder
you'll still get in the creaminess of
the greek yogurt and that extra vitamin
k2 to help get the calcium out of your
arteries and into your bones okay so
this is true k2 is an important nutrient
for bone and heart health because if we
imagine calcium as the currency that
goes into the bone bank it has to flow
through the blood vessels before it can
go into your bones vitamin k2 is kind of
like the bank teller that draws the
calcium out of the bloodstream and
deposits the calcium paycheck into the
bones and this is really key for our
heart health as well because
calcification of our arteries is a risk
factor for heart disease now vitamin k2
is mainly found in animal products like
dairy and meat and while autumn claims
you can only get it if the dairy comes
from grass-fed cows research that tested
almost 150 dairy samples didn't even
test or differentiate grass-fed products
yet they still found k2 across the board
what actually matters more than the
bougie grass-fed label is the fat
percentage since vitamin k2 is a
fat-soluble vitamin and the research
suggests that low or no fat dairy has
just five percent of the k2 of full fat
this is something that autumn doesn't
even mention in her ebook from what i
could see and seeing as most people
can't access grass-fed dairy because
it's expensive or harder to find i feel
like this is a missed opportunity to
educate inclusively that i slightly
reduce the amount of sugar so in this
we're now using about a quarter cup of
blueberries and removing the half banana
it actually still is pretty sweet
especially if you're using protein
powder but with this newest update to
the 21 day intermittent fasting program
i slightly adjusted some of the recipes
to make them better suited for your
goals and considering there's so many
people who are carbohydrate sensitive i
mean what is it like 100 million 100
million 100 million americans have
pre-diabetes or diabetes that's like one
out of every three americans making a
smoothie that still tastes great but
doesn't have so much sugar in it is
really helpful for all of us we also
have two tablespoons of coconut butter
that's going to provide the high quality
fat to keep you satiated a tablespoon of
hemp seeds hemp seeds are actually a
great plant-based protein source of
complete protein not to mention high
quality fat source as well and then a
tablespoon of chia seeds i just love
using chia seeds in pretty much all my
smoothies because it has so much fiber
in it so you really get that extra fiber
component in there too okay lots to
unpack here first of all this smoothie
looks delicious we have a good amount of
calories we've got fiber healthy fats
and protein all the different seeds and
the coconut oil and the protein powder
and the greek yogurt but it's very low
low carb with like a measly quarter cup
of berries and while she mentions at one
point that the recipe used to have a
half a banana in there she said that she
cut that out because of so many
americans having diabetes we have a
problem
this is so problematic and misinformed
folks even if you have diabetes you can
have carbs you can have a [ __ ] banana
and if you're putting the banana in a
smoothie like this which pairs it with
tons of healthy fats and protein and
fiber i really see zero cause for
concern
nobody freak out
any blood sugar response is going to be
buffered by all of those hunger crushing
compounds and i mean i don't even think
she has diabetes so this makes even less
sense especially as a post-workout meal
where we know ideally we want a one to
three ratio of protein to carbs i just
kind of feel like she misunderstood the
assignment and then while i'm blending
up my smoothie i'll have my acv sipper
which is a recipe also from the 21 day
intermittent fasting program it's a
diluted apple cider vinegar to help ease
the transition from a fasted to a fed
state so i understand the rationale for
the apple cider vinegar sipper since we
do have research that vinegar may help
to reduce the blood sugar and insulin
response and temporarily increase
subjective satiety and in her ebook she
does remind people that this is a tool
not a magic bullet it's not going to
undo the insulin spiking effects of like
a massive cookie binge and she says this
herself which i really appreciate and
while we don't have direct evidence that
it can help ease the transition from
fast to fed state i can see the line of
thinking here because she's trying to
kind of keep that first insulin bump of
the day as controlled as possible but in
real life the evidence suggests that our
insulin levels are pretty tightly
regulated and controlled in healthy
individuals so this is a non-issue for
her in my books having said that if she
likes a sipper and it feels good to her
and it doesn't seem to like erode her
teeth or upset her stomach as it does
for a lot of us then hey like i say sip
sip away you go girl for this recipe i'm
using three eggs which will amount to
about 18 grams worth of protein i try
and aim to have about 25 grams of
protein per each meal just for my own
goals so just having three eggs is a
little bit low for my protein needs so
for this recipe instead of the avocado
i'm going to be swapping that out for a
little bit of a high quality grass-fed
cheese so instead i can get the fat but
also a little bit of protein to add onto
the eggs with the cheese and then for a
fiber component i'm using about a cup of
spinach meal will typically be around 2
30 p.m again this looks delicious and i
love that we've got a solid amount of
fiber protein and fat but again where
are the carbs intermittent fasting is
restrictive enough for most people so we
also layer in low carb like most people
would find it really hard to feel
emotionally satisfied like folks let's
not burn the candle at both ends i don't
snack between meals this is so crucial
to make sure that you're still getting
the gut healing benefits and if you're
having difficulties losing weight
getting more of those breaks between
meals can help the body to more easily
shift back into fat burning yes and
probably not yes for folks who have
compromised guts like those of us with a
history of sibo for whom stimulating
that migratory motor complex is really
super key we do want to try to give our
bodies a solid few hours between meals
most healthy guts don't have to be so
deliberate about it since the mmc only
takes about an hour and a half to two
hours to complete but yes if she has a
history of functional gut disorders
trying to space out meals and snacks
does have merit as for fat burning
theoretically yes but in practice not a
big deal as i discussed in my video on
intermittent fasting and insulin here
insulin is a fat storage hormone on
paper but in real life it doesn't seem
to have a huge impact on weight gain or
loss when at energy balance it doesn't
like cheat the dieting system so to
speak and we know this because when the
calorie deficit is the same folks with
and without diabetes or insulin
resistance will lose about the same
amount of weight so while a higher carb
or like a grazing diet does transiently
increase insulin levels which kind of
boots you out of that fat burning mode
it doesn't seem to affect weight without
like a caloric surplus or deficit we're
kind of splitting hairs here again let's
think big picture so my last meal of the
day for tonight is going to be my
pumpkin chili it's extremely simple and
also the protein component is really
versatile this looks delicious but
surprise surprise still keeping it
low-carb over here
i mean i'm shocked and if this like
lights up her life great i just know
that even if i ate like a huge bowl of
that chili i would not be able to go to
bed feeling satisfied i would absolutely
find myself craving carbs in the several
hours from 7 30 p.m to whenever she goes
to bed and like immediately upon waking
and that's why i don't love intermittent
fasting for a lot of people in fact we
can talk about the insulin suppressing
and the growth hormone stimulating
benefits all we want but as i discussed
in my intermittent fasting video right
here the effects that these factors have
on a healthy body are actually really
small evidence suggests that small
natural variations in human growth
hormone have little to no effect on
weight loss and insulin levels are
tightly regulated in healthy people so
they don't really have a huge impact on
weight loss either and most of the
insulin benefits in fasting occurs when
you front load your carbs in the morning
and then cut off eating by midday but
autumn like most fasters aren't doing
early time restricted eating so she's
not actually really getting the benefits
that she obsesses over in every video
and yet these two things are often
touted as the secret to why intermittent
fasting is different when in reality if
we just eat fewer meals we tend to
actually eat less we're just kind of bad
at making up for missed calories that my
friends is ultimately what results in
weight loss i mean as far as i'm
concerned autumn worked out like three
times in the day and ate under 1700
calories only 27 of which were carbs i
would also lose weight or maintain a
very lean body composition if i kept my
glycogen stores depleted and was in a
chronic caloric deficit like that i
gotta say like i bought autumn's ebook
and while i appreciate that there were
34 studies cited which is a lot more
than most wellness influencers would
cite she seems to overlook a lot of key
studies that would refute or downplay
her position and ultimately i feel like
a lot of it is missing the forest from
the trees for most people intermittent
fasting isn't the holy grail to health
it's a tool in the toolbox that works
for some people because we suck at
making up for the calories when we skip
a meal in some people it actually
results in weight gain and in extreme
cases it may be dangerous for hormones
so it's not benign and it's not
appropriate for a lot of people i think
ultimately if you feel good eating on a
particular regimented schedule then
whatever like it makes sense for you to
continue to eat that way autumn should
feel empowered to eat low carb and to
fast because it seems to work for her
but when an influencer recommends a
singular way of eating to others and
monetizes a how-to program on it to the
public then i just expect them to be
transparent and based on everything i've
shared i'm not convinced by the
one-sided data consistently cited and
shared now to throw autumn a bone i will
say that i think autumn does offer a ton
of great recommendations and tips for
newbie and advanced intermittent fasters
so if this is a way of eating that works
for you and you enjoy definitely check
that out but i do think the low carb
recipes and the fasting regimen would be
a bit of a hard pill for most to swallow
but on that note that is all that i have
for you guys today thanks again to
buildbar for sponsoring if you like this
video be sure to give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below on who you'd
like to see me review next subscribe to
the channel and i'll see you next time
on abby's kitchen bye
[Music]